penda
on est
moche parlant ne bouge pas
c'est comme chez lagache alors ce que
vous préférez en vous
la détermination ce que vous haïssez en
vaut
une certaine forme d'égocentrisme le
plus grand moment de votre vie c'est une
équipe des gamins que j'ai pris un
sixième et que j'ai amené au titre
national scolaire junior italien un
sixième au s'est entraîné en 5e et 4e
tous les joueurs se voyaient entre midi
et deux on mange on mange un sandwich
s'entraîner et le jour où ils ont eu la
médaille d'or a été extraordinaire vous
savez quand on est vachement aux autres
oui oui oui mais c'est toujours si j'ai
des enfants nés d'un premier mariage oui
mais j'ai des enfants comment dirais je
si toujours pareil dans ce métier vous
êtes obligé de donner aux autres ce que
vous n'existez qu'à travers les autres
mais est-ce que vous n'êtes pas aussi en
train de vous servir royalement la part
du temps il ya toujours la question je
suis pas l'abbé pierre carayon clair le
pire moment de votre vie bon mais c'est
c'est le décès de mon père assassiné
donc je pourrais rien faire d argent au
bout du drop sur la traite c'est à dire
ce deuil cruel aperçu du père assez
terrible je pense que pour tout un
chacun mais ça m'est arrivé au plus
mauvais moment c'est à dire que
j'apprends la nouvelle alors combien de
battre l'espagne c'est à dire que je
suis dans un état de féliciter est
totale et juste derrière mon ami au
téléphone qui me dit non mais
apparemment
c'est là le dos alors là c'est une
histoire sordide parce que en fait si
vous voulez c'est une chance parce que
c'est la femme de joueur qui était
jalouse de mon charme parce que ça
remonte à très loin a le dos à dos et à
la fin des années 80 bon c'est vrai que
l'image du méridional peut-être toujours
un petit peu bronzé avec les ray ban et
la démarche est déjà un petit peu
claudiquant un petit peu aussi oui faut
bien reconnaître mais à mon avis à
l'époque où ça ça m'a jamais plu par
contre et je les assume mais il est
joueur ne se permettent pas sauf après
les victoires 16 matches et marqué là
ils pouvaient se permettre au début du
championnat du monde parce qu'ils
m'appellent d'or
non alors aldo qu'est ce que vous
préférez dans le sexe
qu'est ce que la femme toute la femme
oui oui je vais le chat de pâtes d'état
je suis assez bon public là j'ai pas dit
toutes les femmes chez la femme est ce
que vous détestez dans le sexe
bec à certains moments du fatigué quoi
ouais ça s'arrête il faille qu'il faille
que ce s'arrête la plupart du temps de
mon fait d'inquiéter je pourrais de
l'ibex mais si demain